à 76 ans eugène ionesco est l'auteur
dramatique le plus joué dans le monde
ces records ne se comptent plus il est
traduit dans 17 langues
l'un de ses chefs-d'oeuvre la cantatrice
chauve est jouée au théâtre de la
huchette à paris depuis 35 ans et les
dons de jeanne ionesco ne s'arrête pas
au théâtre et la littérature
il est également peintre et ses oeuvres
sont actuellement exposées au centre
beaubourg
sylvie marron marion pardon jean-marie
je vis ici avec ma femme je vis avec ma
fille et ses deux présences me suffisent
me rassure
notre call j'ai dépensé 75 où je suis
plus près de 80 de ce vent 15 alors le
nombre de morts qui se sont entassés les
uns après les autres ça fait des
montagnes
eugène ionesco 76 ans son dernier livre
ne parle que de ça la mort mais aussi un
peu de dieu de peinture de sa femme des
consolations qui se trouvait sur le tard
pour tenir bon
si longtemps que nous sommes ensemble on
se connaît très bien et s'abstient aide
non tu es là elle va fabrice sagement
elle me comprend très bien et quand j'ai
très très peur ça arrive la nuit se
nommait dans son lit et sa présence sa
respiration
la senteur de sa peau
quel sens comme il ya 40 ans tout ça ça
me rassure
ai je pu m'endormir beaucoup plus facile
donc avec un thème est à la littérature
me semble utile
je ne supporte pas les romans je ne
supporte pas les nouvelles et si je veux
avoir quelque chose de plus frais je
fais de la peinture
la peinture est pour moi une véritable
terre à petit un objet coloré freaky
libre avec un autre il faut que la
tangente soit respectée et alors je me
dis puisque je met de l'ordre dans ses
petits tableaux dans ces petites choses
que je fais probablement que
on pourra faire de l'ordre dans
l'univers un peu d'ordre
la quête de la foi et beaucoup d'amour
c'est la formule ionesco pour continuer
son chemin